windows10 isn't coming to your computer
until later this year but I have your
first look right now the Start menu is
back in a big way instead of being taken
to a large Start screen like in Windows
8 you can organize your apps right in
the bottom left corner you can take it
fullscreen to Cortana Microsoft's
personal assistant is also available
right on the toolbar for searches and
questions
there are also some navigation changes
ghandar the charms on the right-hand
side of the screen now you'll find your
notification panel there but the best
part may be how you manage open windows
now you can see your open apps by
swiping in from the left and you can
arrange them on different virtual
desktops one of my biggest problems with
Windows 8 was it never knew what device
I was on but with Windows 10 it now
knows if I'm on a laptop or a tablet I'm
doc the keyboard and it will prompt you
to enter tablet mode which makes the
Start menu larger and takes apps
fullscreen attach the keyboard and it
will take you back to the traditional
desktop and turn those full screen apps
back into Windows me and my stylus are
going to go back to playing with Windows
10 but will have way more coverage on
Microsoft's newest operating system
later in the year